exhibiting in the Netherlands the New
York Times reported this and here's what
they said
modern well I'm saying modern art is
what it represents in this case you are
looking at enormous turd sculptures okay
there are times described them as turd
sculptures it says in the New York Times
exhibition where you can walk through
the excrement
you know when body functions become
become the focus of art we're in trouble
how did we get from the Pieta to fecal
matter how did we get there this looks
right Sarah
these are enormous wants to tell us that
life turned a big pile of steaming and
it looks like your big dog Jimmy walked
in there on Persian rugs look it's like
it's like an enormous dog just drop this
now what this means why it's here I
don't know this group of gelatin is
their name they've done sculptures in
the past in 2005 they did a sculpture of
frozen urine I kid you not the only
thing I like about this exhibit it is
everybody will come to the same
determination it is crap all right now
we have a new exhibit speaking of
exhibit set it's not crap no this is an
icer exist this is at the african
american museum smithsonian museum in
washington Oprah Winfrey has a big big
exhibit a taxpayer shrine to Oprah 240
artifacts she walked through it with
Gayle King she was very moved because
people wrote guestbook entries no garage
read one watch okay
it's called watching Oprah
American culture I love it Oprah Winfrey
is the reason I love myself so fiercely
you know that my voice matters oh that
makes me want to cry the bottom line is
this was your gift and our gift to
America and so we want to thank you for
that but the guy was driving me this
morning his name is ií'd he was started
watching The Oprah Winfrey Show and he
would see her walk in the aisle with the
audience and some of the issues she
would cover she would cover and he said
I just knew that she was a good human
and when I say all the things that are
in this room it is getting to me and at
the bottom line she really is a human
who just wants to do good in the world
[Music]
but I do hope when the seen and unseen
exhibit opens at the very small
italian-american museum somewhere on the
mall that you'll give an emotive report
like that here on Fox when you stand
there here's my question
Oprah gets 4000s like a millimeter the
the seminal artistic figure in the
african-american experience he's gay he
gets a horn in a case
no no exhibit hall for him why can't we
see Louis Armstrong's movies live
performances Sammy Davis jr. w eb Du
Bois great african-americans where are
their full-size exhibits here I think
this is a bit of overkill hit a headline
the new Oprah exhibit looks like a
reward for her 21 million dollar
donation right but honestly she deserves
this she's the largest single donor to
this museum they already have a theater
named after her here here's what I want
the Phil Donahue exhibit he was the
first big hit talk show before Oprah and
how did she get his own little and the
saddest news was Charles Krauthammer
announcing that he only has a few weeks
to live he tweeted out a comment about
this saying due to cancer it's
Harbor he sat in this chair and I our
prayers and thoughts are with him a
great mind a great elegant writer by the
Fox News audience for sure